welcome back to the rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and ant-man brought a bit of
grounded humor back to the MCU and also
an alternative engine that the Avengers
hijacked for time travel the film's
experimentation and made it one of the
most important or infinity saga
re-watched for the future of the MCU
let's break down all the tiny details
you overlooked in ant-man to see how
this movie set up endgame and young the
openings needs a flashback to 1989
showing the early construction for
shields Triskelion later shown completed
in Winter Soldier the D aged Hank Pym
meets with an aged up Peggy Carter
Howard Stark and Mitchell Carson the
comics Mitch Carson was a SHIELD agent
who was supposed to take on the ant-man
suit but he ended up turning dark he got
a nasty facial scar which Hank might
also allude to by calling back the face
slam later how's your face here Carson
is secretly a Hydra agent which might be
a nod to the third ant-man the comics
Erik O'Grady who works for Hydra Hank is
pissed that shield is trying to
replicate his Pym tech some believe that
Hanks distressed of Howard could have
been caused by caps feeling Pym
particles when Hank and Howard were both
at Camp Lee High in 1970 maybe pink
might have blamed Howard for that but
that would all depend on how you
interpret in games time travel logic
something that that movies writers and
directors disagree on so how are we
supposed to know here Howard says don't
let your past determine the future an
interesting quote reflecting in Howard's
attitude toward Tony explored back in
Iron Man 2 I'm limited by the technology
of my time and it ends up coming full
circle when they meddle with Howard and
Hank and in game no amount of money ever
bought a second of time smart guy on
many levels this ant-man film is all
about passing the torch ant-man is the
first real multi-generational legacy
hero Explorer to them CU and it gives
this cinematic universe a roadmap for
how to pass power from one generation to
the next
and how that can be a good thing we meet
Scott laying on his way out of San
Quentin prison the same Bay Area prison
Frank Castle did some time in and in the
Sony Marvel Universe that's like weirdly
connected to the MCU apparently the
prison cletus kasady carnage is hanging
out in Scott Lang was introduced to the
MCU in promos with whi H reporter
Christine Everhart from the early Iron
Man movies I reported on Tony Stark and
gall Mara
leave me your no Tony Stark thank God
picking him up in the now legendary
ex-con van is one of the best MCU
contributions Lewis oh yeah I still got
my scar from a year ago oh yeah yeah you
know what
still don't come on Louise his boxing
skills actually hurt just throw away we
do see him a knock out a guard later
Scott gets a job at Baskin Robbins Jerry
could you just to take care of the city
of things Scott's big name Jack and his
co-worker Darby are nods to Red's
children Jack and Darby sadly
baskin-robbins always finds out it's got
heads home he passes a cipher pingo doce
the beverage that Bruce Banner worked in
a bottling plant for in Brazil in the
Incredible Hulk and the Milgram Hotel is
a nod to Al Meldrum a writer and artist
for Marvel Comics
Hank returns to his old Pym tech lab his
security check-in gives us a close-up of
his keys with this Russian tank on the
keychain it's marked 1 5 3 and it shows
up moments later in the shield footage
of him ant-man in action Hank shrunk
down this real tank from its Cold War
missions it shows up a few more times
throughout the movie before it blows
back up check-offs tank Darren cross
great some and notice the guy on the
tour later suggests my carts gonna be a
Hydra affiliate slide he's got this
barely visible neck tattoo establishing
him as a member of the ten rings Network
a deleted shot from the sequence would
have given us a clearer look at it but
you can see it again later
when he gets knocked out that's a scary
scary glare of a Mandarin Boyle's nice
day Network who first kidnapped Tony
Stark who broke the fake Mandarin out of
Seagate prison and is behind the real
Mandarin in the upcoming shang-chi was
here in this movie trying to get Hank
Pimm's resizing tech Darren chose shield
footage of Hank as ant-man during the
Cold War and ant-man that's what they
called you right Hank silly I know
propaganda Jose to astonish tales to
astonish was the Marvel title ant-man
first debuted under in 1962 this archive
footage is this movie's way of
acknowledging a man's history as a
legacy older era superhero who passes
the torch on to a new generation Scott
Lang takes the torch in this movie but
in this moment hope Van Dyne forces this
smile at this history because she knows
she's more worthy of that torch though
later the wrong choice Pym successor
hopes ascendancy as the wasp because his
failures as a mentor as a father forced
us to spread our wings and on a meta
level this whole movie is a torch passed
on PIMs flashback mission here was from
the film's original prologue that would
have showed Hank in Panama in the 60s
one of the many sequences from the
movies original writer director Edgar
Wright director of the Cornetto trilogy
Scott Pilgrim who developed his version
of ant-man over a decade but disputes
over this movie's connectivity to the
MCU led to Wright and his partner Joe
Cornish leaving and being replaced by
director Peyton Reed and Adam McKay who
rewrote the script with Paul Rudd thus
the complicated writing credit on this
movie Darin unveils the Yellow Jacket
suit which was originally an ultimate
suit worn by ant-man in the comics the
texture of the suit in the vault windows
take a hexagonal honeycomb pattern
Yellowjackets are often confused with
these but they don't make honey maybe
reflecting Darren's failure to
appreciate his own tech in the promo
video the Yellow Jacket assassinates
targets and notice this blaster sound
effects to curio twitter to the sound
designers use the sound effect of the
8080 blasters from the Empire Strikes
Back and you can hear the sound again in
the final fight poor Frank is our
Admiral body in this scenario with Daren
putting the sand on the shoulders his
signal his horrific murder the most
haunting and disgusting death of the MCU
to date which yet really triggered me
when he Pat's Hank the same way later
Scott crashes the birthday party of his
daughter Cassie Lange an older version
recently played by Emma Furman and
Avengers end game perhaps the Future
Young Avengers stature Scott gives her
terrifying rabbits
the voice of this rabbit is actually
cameo by spongebob boy sectors I'm Kenny
Lewis tell Scott about the job using his
hilarious telephone bit he tells me that
she's working as a housekeeper now right
and she's dating his dude Carlos was a
shot caller from a monster babe and she
tells him about to do that she's
cleaning for right that he's like this
bigshot CEO that is all retired now but
it's loaded never repeats my call for
every MCU film to proceed with an
opening short Louis recapping the
previous events in the jazzy seventy
four time signature heist music that
plays here later inspired these similar
jazzy heist theme that plays during the
endgame time heist planning sequence out
works now we got to figure out the when
and the where when Kurt picks up the
cleaning crew uniform the company is
very uniform and linen and on to the
movies art department head Susan Berg
Tom breaks in a hex house and finds the
ant-man suit holy design actually
resembles Ultron's head because the
designers based it on the fact that in
the comics Ultron was created by Hank
Pym but not in the cinematic universe
and Scott puts on the suit triggers two
Pym particles and shrinks the designers
of this movie displayed the resizing
with these ripple lines inspired by
ant-man's resized into the comics which
was based on stop-motion photography and
multiple exposure shots when shrunken
they fill the surroundings with dust
mites floating particles as the world
would look from a smaller vantage point
based on macro photography and when he
lands outside the tub he cracks the
floor tile because this movie
establishes the bunkers physics of
shrinking an object by reducing the
distance between atoms while maintaining
its weight and density
yet somehow Hank can carry the weight of
a tank on his keys yeah there's a reason
ant-man logic is the most frequently
requested topic for big question Scott
tumbles through his downstairs neighbors
rave in a vacuum and a mouse all this
scrambling door a shower and running
into a mouse we're inspired by a man's
first adventure in 1962 and some have
wondered if this mouse is the same
rodent in endgame that scurried over the
man controls to release Scott from the
quantum realm and save the universe I
love the idea but it's unlikely they
have a lifespan of two to three years
and Scott's return an end game was eight
years after this there's a cameo by
Garrett Morris who was technically the
first actor to play ant-man on screen in
a 1979 SNL sketch Hank help Scott escape
from jail and he runs across a newspaper
with this headline
who's to blame for sokovia
Senate Oversight Committee demands
independent investigation tying together
the aftermath from age of Ultron with
this the Cobie Accords introduced in
civil war they also bring up these
events later I think our first move
should be calling the Avengers besides
it probably too busy dropping cities
yeah you know some of these details are
tough to spot blend in seamlessly with a
background kind of like a what the heck
is this a sleek front pocket wallet like
the ridge thanks to the rich response
here in this video the ridge wallet is
light and sleek and industrial it's
designed to fit in your front pocket
unlike those bulky 90 style back pocket
wallets that give you a big ass this one
is their titanium black design its
smooth its minimalist blends in
seamlessly that titanium try shrink it
through those atoms ant-man
and hey folks when you go upper
essentials these days just take the
minimal essentials with you to make four
quick hassle-free transactions right the
ridge wallet comes in over 30 styles and
colors including carbon fiber and burnt
- titanium it holds up to 12 cards and
still has room for cash assuming you
still use those dusty old greenbacks
every Ridge wallet comes with a lifetime
guarantee and they'll let you test drive
it for 45 days and send it back for a
full refund if you don't love it it's
got 30,000 five-star reviews so they're
doing something right they also have
great backpacks and travel bags with
RFID blocking pockets and optional
device charging batteries fathers days
coming up in June and the ridge wallet
would make a great gift for pops Ridge
wallets are chainsaw proof so and Dad
trips in the garage he doesn't have to
worry about a touch up on that vasectomy
Koli get 10% off today with free
worldwide shipping and returns by going
to Ridge comm slash new rock stars
that's Ridge comm slash new rock stars
and use the code new rock stars find the
link in the video's description
Hank explains to Scott his retirement
why don't you wear the suit you think I
don't want to I can't spend years
wearing it they took a toll on me this
toll is the suit's effect on the brain
mentioned moments earlier can affect the
brains chemistry
I don't think Darren realizes this and
you know he's not the most stable guy to
begin with later on in the movie hope
brings this up again with Darren it's
not
you are its the particles altering your
brain chemistry though notice that brain
chemistry line was sent off screen I'm
guessing it was dubbed in later to make
this all clearer why is this important
well part of Hank PIMs legacy from the
comics is a very controversial 1981
issue where he assaults Janet van Dyke
was reportedly a miscommunication
between the comic writer and the artist
whatever happened fans turned against
the character of marvel ended up
explaining hank was having a mental
breakdown and they expelled them from
the Avengers but this is part of the
reason why it's helped they do pass the
torch how longer someone's in the
spotlight the more likely they'll do
something I'll piss everyone off MCU
Hank of course never abused Janet but
Darren exemplifies the cautionary tale
of how this tech takes a physical toll
on one's body and both Hank pimps Tech
and the stark family Tech he despises
Harry expiration dates that require
these heroes to pass down the power onto
a new generation and that includes
probably Cassie Lang stature one day I
mean Scott's already starting to lose it
it's out of context but I had to do it
Hank advises Scott's suit has power the
man harnesses that power another example
of how ant-man and the Starks are more
alike than different if you're nothing
without this shoot then you shouldn't
have it okay sound like my dad Hank
broadens the MCU for us it means that
you would enter a quantum realm what
does that mean it means that you would
enter a reality where all concepts of
time and space become irrelevant the
quantum realm was the Institute's name
Fortnum mike reverser microworld
subatomic ax is gone by a bunch of
different names but Marvel couldn't use
them at the time because all this was in
a way associated with the Fantastic Four
which was then a Fox property Hank
reveals Janet's disappearance into the
quantum realm shrinking between atoms to
stop an ICBM later when Scott go
subatomic a shadow of the wasp appears
on screen and reflecting from his helmet
setting up Janet's return in ant-man in
the wasp they infiltrate what Hank
thinks is an old stark warehouse without
knowing that the Avengers relocated
there at the end of age Voltron if you
look closely at the line you can see the
burn mark that Thor's Bifrost left there
that man has no regard for lawn
maintenance you think about it neither
to Scott
Falcon Sam Wilson appears and Scott
takes them down using the same move hope
use on Scott earlier just why she reacts
so impressed here and in case you're
wondering director Peyton Reed just
revealed that the person Sam is radioing
to is Natasha Black Widow Louise Kurt
and Dave helped them break back into the
lab so you know their mix the second
Marvel movie in a row to sample the
songbook of their new corporate
overlords
Darren Tran Scott but Scott escapes and
Carson also manages to slip away with
crosses yellow shrinking vial
deliberately you left open for the MCU
to return to later add that to the list
of the leader in abomination a bunch of
these guys Scott uses the guards attacks
against them leaping through the bullet
hole that they just shot using their gun
barrel as a running start before using
the other guys tie to flip them through
the glass some of this choreography was
taken directly from Edgar Wright's test
footage shown in Comic Con in 2012 Scott
confronts Darren in the helicopter did
you think you could stop the future ice
Darren a heist is exactly how Scott
helps the Avengers stop the future in
endgame move on they fight inside the
suitcase they accidentally play The
Cure's disintegration on the phone
notice how all of the tactical uses of
the shrinking suit that Darren promised
back in his promo video earlier gets
shown throughout this movie in the plan
to bring Darren down drinking through a
keyhole going into a briefcase disabling
the lab crashing a helicopter and
lasering through people's heads study
with some some weapons really
foreshadowing his own death Darren
targets Cassie and the final fight takes
place on her Thomas the Tank Engine set
which the rights holders to Thomas only
allowed under the condition that no
character can be tied to the train track
and Thomas isn't depicted doing anything
evil I guess crushing a cop car ain't
evil
got shrinks between the titanium atoms
of Darren's suit breaking its regulator
and causing his arm to horrific ly
shrink off his body
[Applause]
thankfully this brings an end to Phi
keys phase to amputation frenzy and will
shrink it down for you this time Scott
go subatomic
in addition to the wasup of shadow I
talked about earlier he passes a
tardigrade the micro organism that shows
up again then ant-man and the wasp Scott
makes it back out blowing Hanks mind BAC
this photo of Janet you know the one
that doesn't show her face but he framed
it foretells a return in the next film
and foretells Scott's future return
after the five-year gap an in-game the
film closes with another recap montage
from Lewis with Stan Lee's cameo and
another possible nod in here looking for
this dude there's no one seen with like
flashing his French tag who's got Lian
bomb moves right well you got she's like
well we got everything nowadays we've
got a guy who jumps we got a guy who
swings we got a guy who crawls up the
wall you gotta be more specific
spider-man to me though this movie was
written before that deal was signed so
who knows but spider-man like ant-man
gets his own totally different MCU
introduction very soon the second
post-credit scene shows how this will
all tie into the next film Captain
America Civil War with this clip
directed by the Russo brothers
maybe not
I know a guy I love they included the
screen sound effect in there
watch our wake down of Winter Soldier
for more details on that but the first
post-credit scene is the film's true
legacy you can't destroy power all you
can do is make sure that it's in the
right hands it's about damn time
hopes line reflects the fact that wasp
is finally getting her on screen do
despite being part of the original
Avengers lineup in the 60s it's
interesting how this film includes
subtle setups for spider-man in stature
in the Young Avengers and shang-chi and
the 10 rings all titles that appear to
be leading Marvel's face for future
ant-man didn't just set up the wasp in
the mechanics for time-travel an end
game it shows the MCU how sunsetting the
old guard can pave the way for new
heroes in a very entrenched cinematic
universe a trick that they will use
again to pass the torch to Black Panther
- Captain Marvel and if you think about
it with Peter Parker and Tony Stark's
legacy spider-man none of that would
have been quite as good at them so you
didn't have this little guy to lick new
rock stars infinity saga re-watch this
charging forward into the big launch of
Marvel phase 3 captain Burke's of war
and you can join our watch along on
discord by becoming a patron at
patreon.com slash the rockstars follow
me on Instagram and Twitter probably new
rock stars and subscribe to see us break
down the movie that made us all covered
and more speaking goo than Falcon a book
[Music]